>> Greg: HERE WE GO.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYBODY.
WE'VE GOT A GREAT SHOW, RIGHT,
JUDGE?
CHECKING TO SEE IF YOU WERE
STILL HERE.
IT IS THE JUDGE.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
TWITTER SPOKESMAN CONFIRMS
ELON MUSK HAS OFFERED TO BUY THE
COMPANY AGAIN THAT HIS ORIGINAL
PRICE OF 44 BILLION.
APPARENTLY TWITTER THREW IN A
SET OF NONSTICK PANS AND THAT
SEALED THE DEAL.
THE MEDIA PULLING OUT WHAT'S
LEFT OF THEIR HAIR.
CUE THE MONTAGE.
>> HESITATE EVEN ASK WHAT GOOD
ELON MUSK BE THINKING?
RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
>> HE WANTS TO REMOVE SOME OF
THE GUARDRAILS FOR FREE SPEECH.
>> BEING MORE OPEN TO
FREE SPEECH?
>> IT'S KIND OF A HOT MESS.
>> SOMETIMES HE TROLLS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE'S GOING TO
RUN THIS COMPANY.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO A
WEDDING.
THEY REALLY SHOULDN'T BE GETTING
MARRIED.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK OUT.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN ANYTIME SOON IN
YOUR FUTURE.
WAS THAT MEAN?
GOOD.
BEFORE ELON MUSK TRIED TO BACK
OUT OF IT CLAIMING TWITTER WAS
NOT FORTHRIGHT ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF SPAM ACCOUNTS ON THE SITE
ESPECIALLY FAKE ONES LIKE
EVERYONE LOVES BRIAN KILMEADE
2019.
COME ON.
BOTH SIDES WERE DUE IN COURT IN
A FEW WEEKS TO HASH THIS OUT BUT
NOW ELON MUSK CAN OWN THE
COMPANY IN DAY.
WHAT ABOUT THE PURCHASE OF
TWITTER UPSETS YOU QUESTION WHAT
IS IT SAY ABOUT YOU?
IT MEANS YOU'RE PROBABLY IN THE
MEDIA AND YOU'RE PROBABLY A
DEMOCRAT OR IS THAT YOU'RE
JEALOUS HE HAD 44 MILLION TO
SPEND.
THAT'S DOUBLE WHAT I HAVE.
WHY IS HE A THREAT TO THE MEDIA?
IT MEANS THEY'LL WASTE EVEN MORE
TIME ONLINE THAN THEY ALREADY
DO.
BECAUSE OF THOSE BOTS FULL OF
DNC TALKING POINTS AREN'T GOING
TO FORWARD THEMSELVES.
UNLIKE THE MEDIA, MUSK ISN'T
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF
LIMITING SPEECH BUT INCREASING
IT AND WHY SHOULD THAT BE SCARY?
DOES THE MEDIA HAVE A WORD
ALLERGY?
SERIOUSLY, UNLESS YOUR
KAMALA HARRIS, ISN'T MORE SPEECH
A GOOD THING?
YEAH.
WE DO CLAP FOR HER.
VERY POSITIVE BALANCE SHOW.
MY GUESS IS THE ONLY PEOPLE
UPSET ABOUT MUSK ARE THOSE WHO
SEE THEIR GRAVY TRAIN OF LIES
ABOUT TO END.
THEY ARE LIKE KIDS WHO HAD FREE
REIN OF THE HOUSE WHILE THE
PARENTS WERE AWAY ANOTHER
PARENTS ARE COMING HOME SO
THEY'LL SPEND THE NEXT WEEK
CLEANING UP THE MESS YOU AND
YOUR FRIENDS MADE AND YOU'LL
PROBABLY HAVE TO RENT ONE OF
THOSE GIANT VACUUMS FROM THE
SUPERMARKET BECAUSE KAT TIMPF
MORPHED IN THE LIVING ROOM.
BECAUSE KAT TIMPF BARFED IN THE
LIVING ROOM.
THE MEDIA KNOWS WHAT THEY COULD
LOSE.
SUFFOCATING STORIES THAT MIGHT
BOLSTER YOUR POINT OF VIEW.
WE SAW THIS WITH RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, THE ASSORTED RACE
HOAXES, JANUARY 6.
HUNTER BIDEN.
THEY FEAR THEIR NONSENSE MIGHT
GET DROWNED OUT BY MORE NONSENSE
OR WORSE, ACTUAL TRUTH.
THEY MUST FEEL THE SAME WAY MY
COMPETITION DID WHEN I SHOWED UP
ON THE LATE NIGHT SCENE.
THERE ARE LEFT-LEANING STALE.
STOP.
THAT WAS SO GRATUITOUS.
SHOEHORNING THAT IN.
IF TWITTER IS THE COUNTRY'S TOWN
SQUARE THAN ELON BUYING TWITTER
IS SAVING THE COUNTRY.
AS IT STANDS, TWITTER REPURPOSE
HIS INFORMATION IN THE BITE-SIZE
DOCKET WAS FOR JOURNALISTS WHO
FORGOT HOW TO THINK FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE THE DRUGS ARE FIRED
CUTTING THE PRODUCT WITH
SENTINEL AND THEN SUPPLYING IT
TO THE MASSES THROUGH LOW-LEVEL
STREET DEALERS.
TWITTER EXPOSES WHAT WE KNOW TO
BE TRUE BUT RARELY ADMIT.
IT'S NOT JUST OUR EXCHANGE OF
SESSION WITH LARRY KUDLOW'S
SOCKS.
IT'S WORSE.
IT'S THAT OUR OPINIONS COME FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE, OFTEN
ASSEMBLY-LINE LIKE BRAND-NEW
NIKES EXCEPT THEY'RE MADE BY THE
LEFT AND THEIR ALLIES, NOT CHILD
LABORERS WHO WOULD DO MUCH
BETTER JOB LET'S BE HONEST.
IF YOU'RE A REPORTER AT CNN
WHICH ALREADY SHOWS POOR
JUDGMENT, AND YOU CAN FIGURE OUT
WHERE TO STAND ON SOMETHING,
TWITTER MAKES IT EASY.
IT'S THE SAME WAY McDONALD'S
MAKES IT EASY WHEN YOU CAN'T
DECIDE WHAT TO EAT.
SURE, IT'S NOT THE HEALTHIEST
FOR YOU BUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
COOK SO OPINIONS ARE PREMADE, NO
THOUGHT NECESSARY.
IF YOU TALK A LOT ABOUT CRIME,
TWITTER WILL SAY SUCH TALK IS
RACIST.
IF YOU CRITICIZE OUR BORDER
POLICY, OUR OPEN BORDERS, THAT
IS XENOPHOBIA.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT COVID TOO
MUCH, THAT'S JUST
MISINFORMATION.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR KIDS
EDUCATION SUCKING, THEN YOU'RE A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
IF YOU QUESTION GENDER
AFFIRMATION SURGERY, THEN
CLEARLY YOU WANT TRAINS KIDS TO
DIE.
THIS TOWN SQUARE IS MORE LIKE A
BLACK HOLE WHERE TRUTH GOES TO
DIE TO BE REPLACED BY
PROPAGANDA.
LESS A CONVERSATION THAN A
CONTROLLING MECHANISM AGAINST
DISSENT.
IT IS A TOWN SQUARE AND THAT
IT'S JUST LIKE TIANANMEN SQUARE.
AND MUSK IS THE DUDE STANDING IN
FRONT OF THE TANK.
ELON IS TRYING TO FIX TWITTER SO
WE CAN ALL PARTICIPATE AS
OPPOSED TO BEING SHAMED OR
SILENCED.
I GET PLENTY OF THAT WHEN I POST
BIKINI PICTURES ON INSTAGRAM.
NO FILTER EITHER.
HERE'S THE REALLY HUGE TRUTH.
ELON OWNING TWITTER IS BIG
BECAUSE TWITTER ALREADY OWNS THE
MEDIA.
SO MUSK BUYING TWITTER MEANS HE
JUST BOUGHT THEM TOO.
TALK ABOUT TRULY OWNING THE
LIBS.
LEFTIES UNRAVEL WHEN SHE BANGS
HER DABBLE.
THAT SOUNDED DIRTY.
COHOST OF "THE FIVE,"
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
HE'S FRUSTRATED MORE TERRACE
THAN A GOAT WITH THE CHASTITY
BELT.
FORMER MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
ANALYST AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
BRETT VELICOVICH.
IF SHE WERE ANY WHITER AND
THINNER, SHE WOULD BE COVERED IN
MARINARA SAUCE.
SOUNDS LIKE THEY WANT THAT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HIS SHIRT SIZE HAS MORE Xs
THAN KIM KARDASHIAN.
MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND NWA WORLD
TELEVISION CHAMPION, TYRUS.
JUDGE, WHAT A RARE PLEASURE IT
IS TO SEE YOU TWICE IN ONE
EVENING.
>> Judge Jeanine: YES.
WITHIN AN HOUR.
>> Greg: THEY DON'T KNOW THAT.
YOU JUST BLEW THE SECRET.
THIS IS LIVE.
I DON'T SEE YOU ON TWITTER.
DO YOU TWEET?
>> Judge Jeanine: RARELY.
>> Greg: IS AT A DECISION BY
YOU OR MANAGEMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: A DECISION
BY MANAGEMENT.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY BOTS
THERE ARE.
I'M CAREFUL AND CAUTIOUS ABOUT
WHAT I DO.
NOW THAT IT'S GOING TO BE THE
TRUE PUBLIC SQUARE AND NOW THAT
ELON MUSK IS GOING TO BUY IT,
NOW THAT IT'S GOING TO BE OPEN
TO FREE SPEECH, I AM MORE OPEN
TO BEING ON IT.
>> Greg: WANTED YOU MAKE OF
THAT DUDE FROM NBC TWEETING THIS
COULD AFFECT THE MIDTERMS.
>> Judge Jeanine: HYPOCRISY AT
ITS BEST.
TWITTER AND ALL SOCIAL MEDIA,
AND OF EVERYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP, THEY
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
WE KNOW STATISTICALLY THAT A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF AMERICANS
HEARD ABOUT THAT AT MY TO CHANGE
THE ELECTION.
WOULD'VE CHANGED THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION AND NOW
THEY'RE SAYING OH, MY GOSH, OH,
NO, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
FREE SPEECH.
PEOPLE CAN SAY WHATEVER THEY
WANT.
WHAT ABOUT MISINFORMATION?
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE CONSTITUTION AND
FREE SPEECH.
THEY THINK THAT THEY SHOULD
DECIDE WHAT YOU SAY AND WHETHER
OR NOT IT SHOULD EVER BE OUT
THERE FOR PEOPLE TO READ.
THESE ARE THE GENIUSES WHO
BROUGHT US THAT MARY POPPINS
WITH THE MISINFORMATION BOARD.
>> Greg: YES, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS SCARY POPPINS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE SHE IS RIGHT
NOW.
ISN'T THAT INTERESTING.
>> Judge Jeanine: COOKING UP
SOME MORE MISINFORMATION.
>> Greg: BRETT, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
IT'S YOUR FIRST TIME.
MY PLEASURE.
HOLD ON THE SECOND.
WE ARE ONLY SUPPOSED TO HAVE
ATTRACTIVE MEN.
[LAUGHS]
BRUTAL.
THAT'S A JOKE!
OBVIOUSLY HE'S HANDSOME.
HE IS A HANDSOME MILITARY
VETERAN, YOU PEOPLE.
>> Brett: CAREFUL.
MY BOO IS IN THE AUDIENCE.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THE DEAL
GOES THROUGH?
>> Brett: I THINK IT GOES
THROUGH.
THESE WOKE CENTERS AT TWITTER
STOPPING THESE CONSERVATIVE
VOICES SHOULD BE FIRED.
I WILL ALSO SAY I DEFINITELY
ENVY ELON MUSK.
HE SEEMS TO HAVE THIS LIFESTYLE
OF 0Fs CONSTANTLY ME DOES
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
HE'S NAMING HIS CHILDREN AFTER
DRONES AND HE IS GOING TO TAKE
THIS TWITTER PLATFORM AND TURN
IT INTO WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
LIBERALS ARE IN THIS MELTDOWN.
THEY NO LONGER HAVE A PLATFORM
WHERE THEY CAN CENSOR
CONSERVATIVES.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST ISSUE WITH
THIS, THEY ARE UPSET ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GO AND GIVES
FREE SPEECH.
THESE MORONS SAYING IT'S A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, IT'S A
THREAT TO FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
STOPPED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CONSERVATIVE VOICES, REALLY
DESTROYED THE FREE SPEECH IN
THESE CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRATIC
VALUES THAT WE ALL KNOW.
>> Greg: THINGS HAVE FLIPPED.
THE RIGHT WAS THE SPEECH POLICE
AND THE MORAL MAJORITY AND NOW
IT'S THE LEFT.
KAT, YOU KNOW IT'S DRIVING ME
CRAZY?
>> Kat: WHAT?
>> Greg: I HAVE A LEAK IN MY
LEFT SIDE.
>> Kat: THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR MONTHS.
>> Greg: IT MAKES ME LOOK LIKE
I'M ALWAYS CRYING.
THE NEW HATE SPEECH IS
MISINFORMATION.
EVERY TIME I HEAR SO MANY TALK
ABOUT THE NECESSITY TO CURB
MISINFORMATION, I BELIEVE THEY
ARE SAYING GREG, SHUT UP.
>> Kat: THE REASON YOU'RE
AGAINST HATE SPEECH LAWS IS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT GETS TO
DECIDE WHAT HATE SPEECHES AND
MISINFORMATION LOSS, THE
GOVERNMENT GETS TO DECIDE WHAT
MISINFORMATION IS.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULDN'T HAVE
ANY IMPACT ON IT AT ALL.
SORRY ABOUT YOUR EYE.
>> Greg: IT'S OKAY.
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER OPINIONS?
>> Kat: A LOT OF CRITICISM IS
HAPPENING BECAUSE EVERYONE IS
MELTING DOWN BUT I LOVE A GOOD
MELTDOWN.
I BEING COMPLETELY SERIOUS.
WE HAVE BEEN FOR A REASON AS
HUMANS.
THEY SHOW YOU THAT WHATEVER
YOU'RE MELTING DOWN ABOUT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU VALUE.
IT'S A CHANCE TO TAKE A STEP
BACK.
WHAT I AM PUTTING INTO THIS, IS
IT WORTH WHAT I'M GETTING OUT?
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER IT'S A
WEBSITE.
MAY BE RELAXED.
>> Greg: THE PEOPLE MELTING
DOWN ARE THE PEOPLE SHOULD NEED
TWITTER.
99% OF AMERICA IS NOT
ON TWITTER.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT ARE
ON TWITTER ARE PEOPLE LIKE US
WHO ARE ALREADY HAVE A BULLHORN.
WE ALREADY HAVE.
IT'S LIKE THE MEDIA NEEDS THIS
OTHER OUTLET.
YOU NEED TO CONTROL IT WHEN
THAT'S ACTUALLY FOR PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T ON TV.
>> Tyus: WHAT TWITTER IS FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE IT'S THEIR MIRROR,
SHOWS HOW POPULAR THEY ARE, HOW
GREAT THEY ARE.
THEY SAY SOMETHING PITHY AND
EVERYONE TELLS HIM HOW SMART
THEY ARE.
IT'S THEIR MIRROR, THEIR THING.
NOW MUSK IS GOING TO COME IN AND
TAKE AWAY THE MIRROR AND THERE
MIGHT BE PEOPLE WHO SAY WE
FACT-CHECK BACK IN THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE AND IT'S GOING TO
AFFECT ELECTION.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GO OUT AND MAKE STUFF UP AND
HAVE SOMEBODY BACK YOU UP.
IT'S GOING TO COMPLETELY SCREW
UP THIS WHOLE THING.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
EVERYONE JUST TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON?
WE HAVE TO BE THERE.
WHAT IS DON LEMON, DO THE NEXT
TIME AN ENGLISH WOMAN WITH GOOD
HISTORY COMES ALONG AND TWEETS
SOMETHING.
CAN'T BLOCK HER.
YOU'RE NOT THINKING THIS
THROUGH.
>> Greg: NO ONE TAKES A
MIRROR.
>> Tyus: THE WHOLE POINT OF
BEING WOKE IS NOT TO BE ANSWERED
BACK.
YOU JUST SAY SOMETHING.
SORRY, I'M RACIST.
NOW THEY ARE IN HUGE TROUBLE.
LISTENING TO THE EMPLOYEES TALK
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
THE BEST THING TO DO IS THE
PACK.
THIS MILLIONAIRE LIVES IN REAL
WORLD PROBLEMS.
>> Greg: I'VE NEVER BEEN
AROUND PEOPLE WHO CLAIM THEY ARE
GOING TO QUIT WHO ACTUALLY QUIT.
THEY ARE ALWAYS FIRED.
>> Tyus: AND SHOCKED WHEN
THEY'RE FIRED.
CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
>> Greg: LET'S SAY SOMEBODY
ELSE DECIDES THEY'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW THE JERRY MAGUIRE MOMENT
AND THEN JERRY McGUIRE DOESN'T
DO IT.
WAIT A MINUTE.
HE SAID YOU WERE GOING TO QUIT.
I GOT REALLY GOOD INSURANCE.
IF YOU SAY YOU'RE GO